welcome back to another episode of the
stronger by science podcast
today's episode features a ton of
interesting content about optimal
breakfast composition
glycine supplementation for tendons and
ligaments nutrient losses from cooking
muscle knots and trigger points caffeine
tolerance and more
plus you'll question everything you
thought you knew about ant-man
and crabs as always we hope you enjoyed
today's episode but
be sure to join our public facebook
group or our subreddit
to join in on the conversation and let
us know
welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast
this is your host eric trexler i'm in a
great mood the weather is finally
cooling off for fall
and season three pushes forward for
today's episode
i am joined by a special temporary guest
co-host
by the name of greg knuckles greg how
are you doing today doing well
you know to start things off i don't
want to start on a
sour note but i'm afraid i have to a
little
clarification um i don't know if we want
to make a segment for this but if we did
it'd be called the errors
or the corrections segment maybe
retractions
anyway so in a previous episode i
cast doubt upon the idea that bod pod is
the gold standard
for body composition measurement and
someone in the subreddit that we have
brought it to my attention they actually
found a pretty solid reference for it
was the bodpod website
uh reinforcing that uh it is the gold
standard
uh according to them and as we know
given the
robust consumer protections in america
there's no way that someone could ever
advertise a claim that wasn't
just 100 percent ironclad truth correct
yeah so
uh when you're wrong you're wrong uh
coming clean
uh my apologies we'll do better next
time uh so
let's move on to some good stuff we got
a good news segment and greg why don't
you start us off
uh yeah so my piece of good news is
uh the governor of colorado
is pardoning about 2 700 people
with low-level non-violent marijuana
convictions
now given what we've had to say about
marijuana on the podcast previously you
might be wondering
why this is in the good news segment
and it's probably not for the reason
you're thinking basically
i think this is actually a big win for
people who are opposed to marijuana
because the problem is uh you know folks
with a good
conservative family anti-marijuana
values such as myself
we have i will admit been losing the
culture war when it comes to marijuana
uh you know people have been trying to
put forward this bogus narrative that
it's safe
and you know doesn't lead to millions of
overdose deaths per year
etc complete [ __ ] and the thing is
up until pretty recently the nanny state
was pushing people or or was putting
people in these cushy
so-called prisons uh when they were
early in their marijuana addiction which
basically allowed them to get clean
and so we as a society haven't had an
opportunity to see the ravages of
late-stage marijuana addiction
in decades ever since the very good and
successful war on drugs started
so now that all of these very hard
so now that all of these uh just
dastardly hardened weed heads
are getting put back on the street
people are finally going to be able to
see
what uh what how perilous a late-stage
reefer addiction can truly be uh so i
think that this is going to be good
to uh to swing the culture war back in a
positive direction
uh and i'm excited for it no actually
being 100
serious um yeah the fact that
some states that legalized marijuana
still have people in prison
for like just possession offenses
[ __ ] ridiculous so you know better
late than never
glad they're getting out very good um
so i've got two pieces of good news the
first one is
very brief and to the point this was
from the good news network i don't know
how this qualifies as good news but i
figured it was going to be
instructive nonetheless uh so the
headline here
companies with co-workers who don't get
along should encourage
gratitude journalism and this is from a
study i mean this is science greg
this is what science looks like so a
recent study
from the university of central florida
suggested that employees who keep a
gratitude journal
exhibit less rude behavior greg
and less mistreatment of others in the
workplace
so is that good news i don't know it's
definitely useful for some people
uh moving on you know when we started
this podcast there were a lot of haters
who said no one cares about your podcast
you're not going to actually
change society with the ideas you're
putting out there
and so frankly this is just a victory
lap for me because
we talked about open science recently
and how much we support it
and huge huge huge win for open science
so looking through the news
um nature very prestigious academic
journal group of journals
the publisher of nature has agreed
to its first deal to allow summary to
researchers
to publish in the journal with open
access so
this is important stuff you know in many
cases really critical medical
breakthroughs that affect people's
health
and you know that you know the publisher
of nature is saying people deserve to
get this information
uh should be open access do you think
they did this because of our prodding
i think so okay um i i do you have a
different
idea no i mean uh you know i i knew that
we
were basically setting fda policy at
this point but i didn't know that our
reach extended
quite as far as to influence nature as
well
yeah well i think so um and so according
to the terms basically
these research groups opt in to like a
four-year deal
and so in order to kind of calculate the
lump sum price
the publisher had to figure out well
okay what's approximately the cost per
article that we're going to charge
researchers
to publish open access in our journal
after they have self-funded their work
and done all the labor and so you'd be
surprised to find that the sum that they
used for the calculation
uh was a very pretty reasonable
11 000 u.s dollars eleven
11 200 to be exact so a big win for open
science
uh good to see that we are having a huge
impact and i'm sure every researcher out
there is
super stoked to you know pay 11 grand to
publish each article yeah i mean
it brings up the age-old question that
scientists have been asking this whole
time
would you rather uh have an open access
article in nature or would you rather
get a new hyundai
yeah so all the haters out there
who said that you know these publishers
are going to continue prioritizing
profits
at the expense of the open science
movement you're gonna have to eat your
words
and the proof is in the pudding oh man
okay so uh unfortunately despite all
this great news we've shared
we do have a bad news segment our good
news segment really
went off the rails this week it doesn't
matter i mean
last time we just had to like find cute
animal stories like
yeah we're scraping the bottom of the
barrel
my good news segment was look how fat
these bears are and then i just ended up
talking about how much hibernation
sucks yeah and mine was here's a whale
that didn't die
oh okay so let's go on to the bad news
segment
this one's actually relevant to lifting
unfortunately it is yeah so
um
i forget exactly when the story broke i
think it was maybe back in like may or
june
uh we talked about some drama
uh in the international weightlifting
federation
so basically the former president
thomas ajan was ousted last year after
[Music]
i don't think i can yet say he was found
guilty of corruption but
very very very credible
allegations of extreme corruption um
so he was ousted and he was replaced
like we mentioned
uh previously with ursula papandria uh
who is an american and she
basically attempted a process
of starting reform in the sport um
so you know making sure that uh
like policies were being followed
equitably by all of the countries in the
iwf
like trying to make sure weight lift or
trying to make sure drug testing was
uh more echo equitably administered and
universal in
in the sport etc um
and was basically met with like
resistance
every step along the way and uh
the board it seems uh
just got tired of any attempt to reform
the sport
and so they ousted her as interim
president and then
uh they replaced her with uh someone
from thailand
which is interesting because
so uh as as some backstory weightlifting
has been saying that they're gonna
reform and they've been pressured to
reform
by the international olympic committee
by the ioc
because the sport is so dirty um and
like
the ioc has threatened to kick
weightlifting out of the olympics if it
doesn't
shape up uh so they said like okay we're
gonna do some reforms
uh ursula comes in tries to do some
reforms
and they say like no we don't want to do
reforms and so they
they oust her and install someone from
thailand as the new interim president
uh which circling back is interesting
because thailand is [ __ ] kicked out
of international competitions
currently because of so many failed drug
tests
so uh that was an interesting decision
there was
massive outcry about it so they kicked
him out two days later
uh installed uh mike irani who i believe
is british
um so who who knows he might uh
pick up the torch and try to do some
reforms i don't know how that's gonna go
like those moves just happened a couple
days ago uh
but in all of this drama uh at least
two or maybe three members of the board
of the international weightlifting
federation resigned
and so they currently have 17 members on
their board and
seven of them are from countries which
are banned from international
competition
or can only send reduced sized teams to
the olympics
because of how many of their athletes
have failed drug deaths
so that's uh way closer to half of the
board members than
one would want it to be um
so anyway things aren't looking good in
weightlifting right now
uh i i really think like
so you know don't put much stock
in this because i don't follow weight
lifting or like
ioc politics closely at all
but just from an outside observer i
wouldn't be shocked if there's a better
than 50 50 chance that
the now 2021 olympics are
the last olympics we see weightlifting
in like i mean
it could be that uh they completely
change their course
institute some reforms maybe put on
probation for a while and eventually get
back in the ioc's good graces but
boy it looks it looks tenuous at the
moment
so i i don't want to alienate myself
from a big portion of the audience here
but i have to ask
if that turns out to be the case so if
we
soon see an olympics without
weightlifting
do you think that opens up the door for
something like bodybuilding or maybe
classic bodybuilding or
both do you think both could make it in
i mean no all right fair enough time
[Laughter]
time will tell uh for now i'll keep
training
uh no i mean actually that would be
crazy because they're talking about
maybe having esports at the olympics
like not not in tokyo but maybe
the next one or the one after that uh
i know have been rumblings uh regarding
booting wrestling as well
and you know i'm not gonna make any
value judgments here but just like
thinking
back to like the kind of the purpose of
the olympics
originally uh excluding weightlifting
and wrestling but having esports
interesting that's all i'll say well
we'll see what happens
we will okay i think it's about time for
our fan favorite
selling out segment so just a reminder
if you head over to bulksupplements.com
and you use the discount code sbs pod
in all caps at checkout you get a nice
five percent discount off of your order
so we introduced this idea or this uh
this news in our last episode and i got
a lot of pushback some people thought my
example was a little bit ridiculous i
talked about
a scenario in which you saved about 125
000
a year uh from this five percent
discount code
uh which uh you know upon further
reflection i think there was some merit
to some of the pushback that i received
so
that's fine um and i'm gonna present a
different
scenario a little bit more reasonable so
let's say
you save a hundred dollars this year on
your
your supplement purchases and let's say
you invest it in a fund
with a very modest 20 return rate
and you let it ride for a short 85 years
we're talking about 500 million dollars
in supplement savings
um and 100 i mean that's i would love to
see somebody push back on any of the
parameters that i've set in that
scenario
uh greg you've got an addition here uh
related to uh to our selling out segment
yeah i do
so i i don't want people to listen to
the selling out segment
and think that we're only shilling for
bulk supplements and only showing for
companies
that we have some sort of financial
interest
in our listeners using so i just want to
make people aware of
another very very good and very exciting
pre-workout on the market so let me just
read you some of these ingredients
it has agmatine sulfate which is
theorized to help with
pumps citrulline malate similar improves
blood flow
well recently reasonably well researched
beetroot extract we've talked about
some of the ergogenic benefits of
nitrate on here before
l-tyrosine the limit the limiting amino
acid and catecholamine synthesis
good stuff l-theanine uh helps take the
edge off of caffeine
uh it seems to some degree uh it does
have caffeine as well
also very well researched acute
ergogenic
taurine who cares whatever
riboflavin that's a b vitamin how could
that be bad
anyway so i'm sure you're listening to
this and thinking damn
that sounds like a great pre-workout uh
it has a lot of good ingredients but
here's here's the actual kicker
it has a novel delivery method that
i think everyone's gonna be really
excited to hear about
that's right folks it's the world's
first pre-workout vape
uh it's called v-rush and uh
now it's time to drop the bit holy [ __ ]
this is the dumbest idea i've ever seen
um so just to put this in context the
average
vape cartridge has like one milligram
of liquid in it and uh milligramer
milliliter
milliliter i mean i'm assuming it's uh
probably not much of a difference yeah
yeah yeah like the density of it is it's
probably around a milligram whatever
so it has a milliliter of fluid which
should be around
a gram of uh of stuff
so anyway you're supposed to be able to
take 150 hits
per cartridge you're supposed to take
five before each workout
so we're talking like you're consuming
milligrams of liquid which you know
isn't all [ __ ] powder because that
wouldn't be good
so you know like citrulline malate
you're supposed to consume like six to
eight grams
for peak ergogenic effect which is like
six to eight times more than this entire
[ __ ] vape
cartridge so this sets a new global
standard
for underdosed supplements
and also you you were looking into this
before we started recording
there's a decent chance that this is
just completely illegal right
i don't i don't want to make any claims
that are so strong
but i don't think
based on everything the fda has ever
said
i don't think you can market a dietary
supplement to be inhaled
as the method of delivery that seems to
be a line that the fda has drawn
very clearly and so it's possible that
they're not marketing it
as a dietary supplement i don't know
what it would be
but uh but yeah i i the first thing i
looked at you know rick collins who's
been on the show
uh has done a lot of writing when it
comes to like
what is a supplement and what can be and
it's
pretty damn clear you can't just give
like
any route of administration and be like
no we're calling it a dietary supplement
uh you can do that but the fda is
probably gonna send you some letters
uh and be upset yeah and and the other
good question is like
how uh how is this stuff actually going
to get in your bloodstream because
i have no idea because the thing is with
like inhalation
um so like some of the stuff you
inhale can be absorbed across like
mucous membranes
but actual like diffusion into the blood
via the alveoli
is generally just like passive diffusion
basically
um and like most of these things are
relatively large like molecules or
compounds that would need transporters
so like i don't even know that most of
this stuff would actually
enter your bloodstream via inhalation so
um you mentioned that
you know it has to be a supplement a
drug a food or a cosmetic product
it might end up being a cosmetic product
because it might make your lungs
sparkly so if you've ever had a good
aged parmesan
cheese the little crystals in there um
like that that are like a little bit
crunchy those are tyrosine crystals like
the
the tyrosine basically like percolates
out of
um like it becomes undissolved within
like
the mass of cheese and forms crystals so
like it very well could be that you're
just forming like little
parmesan-esque tyrosine crystals in your
lungs
uh which could theoretically be
uh construed as as a cosmetic
procedure wasn't that a big source of
panic
man think back to a time when we had
small things to panic about
wasn't that a source of panic was the
the idea of like vaping lung
like that yeah uh uh why do they call it
popcorn lung
well that that was from uh from
literally just
taking a huge whiff of fresh popcorn
fumes
yeah yeah but but i think they were
saying that like vaping did the same
thing
yeah yeah but that was a concern right
was that like there was like
i think i saw some nasty imaging kind of
going around twitter of like
dude what happened to this lung but uh
yeah so
who knows man anyway all of which is to
say
vape nation uh v rush pre-workout vapes
probably not a good idea okay you want
to move on and do some
feats of strength let's do it um yeah so
uh two feats of strength one of them
from
duronar hiatus and one more recent so
um probably the craziest thing that
happened while we were on hiatus i just
completely forgot to talk about
and that is dave rix squatted 320 kilos
or 705 pounds for a triple
so uh dave competes at 205 pounds
uh 93 kilos uh
he is 61 years young which
is noteworthy because most competitive
powerlifters are
not in their 60s uh and also
most world-class lifters aren't still
getting stronger in their 60s
dave's best squat in a meat
is 718 pounds or uh
325 and a half kilos he did that at 57
years old
so it's four years on uh and he's taking
five and a half kilos less than his best
competition squat doing it for a triple
looks like he very well might squat i
don't know
340 350 so like
770 somewhere in that range if he
competes again
which would be absolutely bonkers uh
and also like that would be
a record in his weight class regardless
of age and it's worth
uh just noting how far ahead he is
uh compared to every other 60-plus year
old
power lifter in his weight class so he
just did 705 for a triple
that's crazy the next best squat in the
205 class
for anyone who's 60 plus is 540 pounds
so he's uh he's squatting 160 pounds
more
than the next best person ever and he's
doing it for a triple
um so like i mean
dude he's [ __ ] strong regardless of
age
regardless of weight class but the fact
that he's doing it at 205 at 61 years
old and still
getting stronger like that's that's
mind-boggling that's ridiculous
and it's not like he's a dude who just
got into lifting like five years ago and
was like a natural at it or something
like dude's been competing since his 20s
like he's in his fourth decade of
powerlifting
still still getting stronger uh
i don't know that that's ever happened
before
has anyone just like meticulously
documented the way he lives like like
have we commissioned a project to
discover
like what his secret is i don't know
does he
put his information out there a lot i
honestly have no idea
someone needs to just do like a deep
dive
biographical piece and just be like all
right dave
let's start from day one dude all of
those like
uh all of those radical life extension
folks should just
pay him any sum of money he wants to
study him intensely
yeah because yeah like he he's on like
straight benjamin button mode
like it's [ __ ] crazy um
other feat of strength taylor atwood uh
recently
destroyed his own world record uh in the
uh 74 kilo or 163 pound class
in uh i don't think it was an
international ipf meet but
i i think it was a usa pl meet i think
it was like pretty local
yeah yeah so um you know competing drug
tested
totaled uh 812 kilos or
1790 pounds again at 74 kilos or 163
that is the best uh the best total
without like raw without knee wraps at
all time
in either the 163 or 165 class
that's even counting people who compete
untested and he's only 23 kilos off of
radoslav petkov's
knee wraps record at
75 kilos so and also i think this was
the
fourth ever raw 11 times body weight
total
so anyway crazy performance all around
he's like 50 plus kilos ahead of the
next closest person in his weight class
he's he's been one of the best lifters
on the planet for a while
uh and he's just he's shifted to another
level
and he's just like putting more and more
space between himself and the
competition so
uh very very impressive lifting from
taylor atwood
all right so moving on um i've got
kind of like a mini research review
segment it's not like a huge research
roundup it's just a brief look
at a couple topics that we've kind of
touched on in the past
so in the past we've talked a little bit
about the idea of
what you should eat for breakfast before
training
right so a lot of people train early in
the morning and they're like
can i just train fasted is that bad for
performance do i need to get some
protein in maybe some carbs
and so there's been in the last like two
years
kind of a little flurry of studies on
this topic
and i got to be honest they make the
answer
almost less clear rather than more clear
as they keep coming out and that's
that's not a knock on the research
itself the studies are quite well done
but but it's a really fascinating topic
so
the first paper that i think is relevant
i'm pretty sure we've discussed it on
the show before
but uh it's called breakfast omission
reduces subsequent resistance exercise
performance it's by naha rudin and
colleagues published in 2019
they looked at 16 resistance trained men
who regularly consume breakfast these
are
habitual breakfast consumers and
you know the quick synopsis of the study
is uh
some people had a carbohydrate-rich
breakfast and then did performance
testing i think it was actually
crossover trial so then they came back
on a different visit
uh and omitted breakfast just kind of
did the the same testing protocol
in a fasted state without that
carbohydrate-rich
uh breakfast and the results are pretty
self-explanatory based on the title
um that the lifters were able to
complete more reps to fatigue for a
couple different exercises
if they had a carbohydrate-rich
breakfast before
exercise so based on that study alone
you would look at the findings and say
oh cool
it looks like you probably want some
carbs prior to exercise
you know resistance training is not
purely glycolytic
but it is it does utilize glycolytic
energy systems so
it would seem pretty straightforward you
want to have plenty of carbohydrate
availability when you begin that
exercise session
but that same group published a paper in
2020 that made things a little bit more
uh complicated so again
naharudin and colleagues in 2020
with this study it was called viscous
placebo and carbohydrate breakfasts
similarly decrease appetite and increase
resistance exercise performance
compared with a control breakfast in
trained males
so basically what they what they found
with this study
uh was that having some kind of
breakfast
uh was better than not having some kind
of breakfast
uh so so basically it was a
carbohydrate-rich breakfast was one
condition
the second condition was water only the
third condition was
it sounds weird a placebo breakfast
so it was like this kind of
i think it was like kind of an orange
flavored sludge
but but that actually really had like
negligible energy content
and pretty negligible carbohydrate
content by extension
and what they found was that having some
kind of sludge was good for for
resistance exercise performance
but there was really no benefit whether
that sludge
was non-caloric or essentially
non-caloric
or an actual carbohydrate-rich breakfast
both of them were better than water but
they weren't necessarily
very different from each other and so
that really throws a wrinkle in the
whole
you know the simple explanation of oh
well you need some carbs around
before training so those results would
suggest that
you know maybe it's a psychological
effect some kind of placebo effect where
people think oh look i'm very well
nourished i got this nutritious
breakfast
now i'm gonna go perform well or it's
possible that hunger
plays a role maybe being hungry during
exercise
just generally sucks and tanks your
performance
um and so now there's a third study uh
relevant to this in the mix
it's a little bit different this one is
by metcalf and colleagues published
recently in 2020
the title is omission of a
carbohydrate-rich breakfast impairs
evening endurance exercise performance
despite complete dietary compensation
at lunch and so the idea here it was
another crossover trial with 11 really
well-trained cyclists
so big caveat we're talking about
endurance performance here rather than
resistance exercise but what was really
interesting was
one group had a carbohydrate-rich
breakfast and then a standardized lunch
and then they performed a time trial in
the evening
i think it was a 20 kilometer time trial
on the bike
the other group or the other condition i
should say
they had uh they basically omitted that
carbohydrate-rich
breakfast but totally made up for it at
the standardized lunch so so they made
it such that
they didn't have that carbohydrate-rich
breakfast
but they still ended up between
breakfast and lunch having the same
energy intake
having the same carbohydrate intake
having the same
macronutrient intake overall and what
they found was
kind of unexpectedly you know this
exercise bout took place
i think it was like four or five hours
after lunch
and you would think well who cares if
you got the carbs at
breakfast and lunch or lunch only you
got all the carbs in
you had four or five hours you should be
able to perform well in the evening
they did notice that there was actually
a small performance
advantage for the group that got the
carbs at breakfast
even though they equated all that other
stuff throughout the day it was
a three percent performance advantage i
think it was about three percent but
you know in really well trained cyclists
uh you know the test retest reliability
should be pretty good um you know
i think they make a strong case in the
paper that you know what they found that
three percent difference
uh was greater than the typical error of
the measurement or the the smallest
worthwhile change of the measurement so
it's a small difference but um it's
probably a
you know quote unquote real difference
based on the measurement techniques
that were used um and so they were
thinking you know
maybe this has something to do with the
time course of
how that glycogen is stored so maybe
there were some slight differences
in liver and muscle glycogen
availability at the time of exercise
even though it was four or five hours
later they didn't seem
particularly enthusiastic about that
explanation of the findings they thought
that it really just kind of came down to
psychology they thought that you know
there has been some research indicating
that you can kind of get a placebo
effect
from what appears to be a nutritious
breakfast in terms of subsequent
exercise performance
and so they're wondering if maybe that
the fact that the the participants knew
they were either having a nutritious
nutritious breakfast or not you know
maybe that influenced
how they self-selected their intensity
during that time
trial so maybe they when they had a nice
solid breakfast in the morning
maybe when they got on the bike that
evening they just felt a lot more ready
to kind of take on the time
trial and push themselves to higher
intensities because that's a really
important thing to keep in mind with a
time trial
is that the load is entirely
self-selected you know you kind of
decide when to push and when to pull
back so
um the the authors of the study were a
lot more they seemed to embrace that
psychological aspect a lot more than the
physiological explanation uh and i gotta
be honest with that four or five hour
time period between
lunch and and the evening exercise
i think it's it's hard to say like oh
that's clearly a glycogen thing
you know i i think there was ample
opportunity to uh
to tuck some of that glycogen away and
and use it later so
it's hard to say for sure which one was
really contributing could be a
combination of both but
it does leave us in an interesting spot
where you know the question that comes
up all the time is like
for a lifter how important is breakfast
and what should my breakfast
look like i think without
question there's two things that we can
say first of all
you probably don't want to be hungry you
probably don't want to be training in a
state where you're fasted
and really hungry
number two i think you should definitely
eat what helps you feel
prepared so something that curbs your
hunger
something that basically saying placebo
yourself into having a nice workout
right but like eating something that
makes sense to you curbs your hunger and
doesn't cause any gi distress during the
exercise during the workout
and then at that point what do we do
about carbohydrate
availability i think it's safe to say
that carbohydrate availability
is either neutral or good um
if you're doing high intensity exercise
you don't want to go into it
thinking how can i reduce my my
carbohydrate availability that that's
going to be a bad thing
we know that really severe glycogen
depletion is going to be bad for your
performance
which does bring me to a slight tangent
which is that
you know resistance exercise is not
exclusively glycolytic but it utilizes
glycolytic energy systems period
i keep seeing people now that low carb
has become so popular and even carnivore
approaches i keep seeing people go on
these rants
you know they'll put up a study and say
oh look resistance exercise only
depletes glycogen by
30 35 whatever you know different
studies
give a different number and it seems
like everyone's working under the
assumption that performance is perfectly
fine
until you reach like zero percent
glycogen yeah and then it's like oh damn
i ran out of glycogen like
they're almost treating it like a gas
tank yeah
and when a lot of people make these
arguments based on those studies
i kind of want to just ask them like
are you necessarily assuming that you
have to get to zero percent glycogen
before performance suffers
and i feel like it's kind of baked into
a lot of those explanations
and i don't see why you would think
that's the case based on the things
we've learned about glycogen in the last
10 or 15 years so
i think the thing is like most people
don't know the things we've learned
about glycogen in the last 10 or 15
years
right like you know like localized
glycogen deposits i i think they think
that
more or less glycogen is uh
uniformly distributed throughout the
muscle and yeah it does kind of deplete
like a gas tank
and as long as you have some there
you're good to go yeah i think you're
definitely right because whenever you
talk to somebody about those studies
who's reasonably informed
they're like where the hell did you find
that yeah and you're like
just in the journals man yeah but it's
inconvenient because i i think we still
have a lot to learn about exactly what
the ramifications are
of those findings so i think people are
just kind of kind of going to ignore
them until we fully flesh out
all of the uh the applications and the
kind of practical consequences but
but yeah just so uh
just so our listeners know what we're
alluding to there um
there's a line of research and one of
the reasons i think this isn't well
known
is there's not a ton of research in this
area because it
uh it basically requires a lot of
equipment that most
exercise physiology labs don't have like
you need to be able to
like study not just like what's going on
in muscle fibers but what's going on in
like
separate like very tiny sub locations in
muscle fiber so it requires like
very high powered electron microscopy
which
most exercise science labs just don't
have because it's very expensive
and also not relevant to most research
that most exercise scientists would be
doing
but basically like glycogen isn't
uniformly distributed throughout the
muscle like there's
there's various like deposits of
glycogen that can be used for different
cellular processes um and
during intense exercise
intramyofibrillar
glycogen is depleted pretty quickly um
and glycogen around the sarcoplasmic
reticulum calcium pumps
is depleted pretty quickly and like
basically
those those are the things using
virtually all of the energy during
exercise
so to power muscle contraction and to
power
like reuptake of glycogen for muscle
contraction
uh and so you know you could be 30
glycogen depleted but like
the 80 glycogen depleted for those
actual depots of glycogen
that matter um it like from an exercise
context
uh and the the mechanistic research
basically what they do is like
they look and see like hey in isolated
muscle fibers
if we deplete glycogen in these specific
areas
what does that do to contractile
performance and
it decreases it very substantially um
so yeah like there's not i don't even
know how you would do
in vivo research on that uh like you
know basically you just have to exercise
people
take a biopsy and like see what it looks
like after
exercise which isn't quite as good
but anyway yeah so that that's basically
what we're talking about
um those very specific glycogen deposits
what happens to them during exercise is
probably
substantially greater and substantially
more important than what's happening to
like
global muscle glycogen levels yeah
and so the reason i bring that up is
there are some reasonable arguments one
could make
that downplay the importance of
carbohydrate in the pre-exercise
breakfast
um you know specifically you know that
second study i talked about where
having just some kind of sludge seemed
to be just as good as a carbohydrate
sludge
there are reasonable arguments you could
make
that lead to saying hey just get
something in before you train something
that attenuates hunger
doesn't necessarily have to be you know
300 grams of carbs
you can make that argument but be
mindful of when people make this
argument down
playing the role of carbohydrate
availability and carbohydrate intake
if they're purely basing it on oh look
at this study it only depleted muscle
glycogen by 35
that is extremely shaky ground upon
which to base
any appraisal of the role of
carbohydrate in the diet
um but anyway you know the practical
conclusions what should we do for this
kind of breakfast
like i said don't be hungry eat
something that helps you feel prepared
and doesn't induce any stomach
discomfort
carbohydrate i would say kind of the
null hypothesis
is that it makes sense to have a decent
amount of carbs in that breakfast but
if you're really adamant about omitting
it there is at least some evidence
suggesting that
you're still probably going to be in
pretty good shape
assuming that the the overall intensity
and volume of your session doesn't
exceed
what has been observed in these studies
makes sense to me
okay now i had another topic that i
wanted to do kind of a brief
mini research review on here so someone
in the subreddit
uh and by the way if you're listening
and you're not familiar we have a new
stronger by science subreddit
and we've got a stronger by science
facebook group that are you know
public groups so please feel uh feel
welcome to join in on the conversation
we'll post the links to both of those in
the show notes but
in the subreddit somebody uh posted a
study um
it was an in-vitro study so immediately
big caveats but
the idea was that there was a huge
increase in collagen production
from uh from glycine uh
application you know so uh the idea was
that a really high glycine concentration
increased collagen synthesis by these
articular chondrocytes
in vitro and they're basically trying to
make the claim that
uh dietary glycine should be really
important
for uh promoting collagen synthesis and
therefore having effects on
you know osteoarthritis but also just
general
uh joint health and pain ligaments
tendons etc so
the study that they posted uh was by
depos lugo in 2018
and the first thing i want to mention
you know the things that jump out are
like 200 percent increase whenever we
look at an
in vitro study you know we we of course
have to be cautious about assuming that
the findings are going to translate
in general but we definitely have to be
cautious that the actual magnitude of
effects
is gonna is gonna translate in a literal
way so
i i would not get too wrapped up when
you see 200 you say wow
that's a big number um so i don't want
to get too fixated on that but i want to
focus on the question
you know does glycine potentially have a
role
for people who are trying to be really
mindful of how their nutrition
might impact uh connective tissue
adaptations to training or
you know even uh you know there's a
collagen component of skeletal muscle as
well but
uh you know re-synthesizing collagen in
you know especially tendons and
ligaments is where you see a lot of this
so we have talked about collagen
and gelatin supplementation in the past
so i forget which episode it was but we
kind of did a deep dive
talking about the current state of
research with collagen
i also wrote a mass article about
collagen as well but
the general findings you know there's
studies by shaw in 2017
clark in 2008 mclinden in 2011
there's quite a few stud a small group
of studies but but there are
a number of studies indicating that
generally speaking
supplementation with either gelatin or
collagen
when combined with vitamin c may have
positive effects related to
collagen synthesis and then downstream
things
such as you know the thickness of a
particular tendon in a study or
self-reported joint pain things that
seem to be
you know relevant when it comes to
collagen synthesis
and the whole idea with uh with gelatin
or collagen supplementation is that
they're high in amino acids that would
be relevant
to the synthesis of of collagen so
specifically gelatin and collagen are
really really high in glycine about
when you look at the amino acid
breakdown of gelatin and collagen
glycine is about a third of it
uh so so glycine is a really heavy
lifter when we
are looking at these studies that
utilize collagen
or gelatin supplementation and again i
do want to reiterate that vitamin c
plays a critical role there so
when we look at the synthesis of
collagen uh
you know the the main things that are
are really important there
uh you know we need uh glycine and
proline
but we also need hydroxylated forms of
lysine
and proline and so the nice thing about
collagen
and gelatin supplementation is it
provides all that stuff
so if you if you just take gelatin or
collagen with a little bit of vitamin c
in there
you've got everything you need and the
vitamin c helps with the hydroxylation
of lysine and prolene so if you're
looking at just kind of the easiest
catch-all nutritional intervention that
maybe might support what you're trying
to do in terms of connective tissue
i think gelatin or hydrolyzed collagen
with a little extra vitamin c
and the vitamin c we're talking about
like uh i think it's like
50 milligrams is typically what they
throw in there i don't even know that
that matters
why why do you say that well i mean so
the reason they throw it in
is vitamin c is like a necessary
co-factor
in one of the steps of collagen
synthesis
um but like most people with
a standard western diet do consume
plenty of vitamin c
like yeah i i just don't see the point
in
needing that vitamin c with the the
actual like
gelatin or collagen itself like at the
time of ingestion yeah yeah
i mean i i if if i were to speculate
it's one of those things you know it's
necessary
uh it's cheap you're never gonna regret
having 50 milligrams of vitamin c
so i feel like it makes sense to just
throw it in
yeah so the the reason i say that is um
like there's a lot of places you can buy
like gelatin or hydrolyzed collagen
supplements
very few of them have vitamin c included
um and all so i i'm thinking about this
from a practical perspective because
like i've tried to do this before like
basically get
gelatin and get vitamin c and mix them
together as like a stand-alone
supplement
uh vitamin c powder is like way finer
than gelatin powder is
and so if you mix it together just like
over time the vitamin c
does pretty much all end up settling to
the bottom anyways just because like the
grains are finer
um so like i i
you know you could go to bulk
supplements.com buy both of them
uh and just keep them in like separate
bags and use like a big scoop of
collagen and just like
a tiny little like thimble full of
vitamin c because like 50
50 milligrams isn't much yeah anyway
it just seems like a lot of trouble and
i really just don't think you need that
extra vitamin c
yeah i mean so that's my hot take wow
that that's a very hot take so
um how about this let's meet in the
middle
try not to be vitamin c deficient is
that a fair statement
yes okay i'm glad i'm glad we could
compromise there
um but anyway yeah so if you're looking
for just kind of the catch-all
supplement
and you're like listen i want to give
everything that's necessary
for for new collagen synthesis that's
kind of the easy route but
like i said glycine plays a pretty big
role there
um you know it's a third of of the
collagen
um or the gelatin um in terms of the
amino acid breakdown approximately a
third
but you know when i wrote my mass
article i wrote in the conclusion
that i'd be curious to see if you know
these potential benefits
of gelatin and collagen hold up in the
context
of a diet that's already high in vitamin
c and sufficient intake of protein from
diverse protein sources
particularly including sources high in
glycine
so i kind of singled out glycine there
uh
and the reason by the way before i move
on i should say
the collagen gelatin stuff is still
pretty speculative it's not like a rock
solid case that
yeah supplement with those it's gonna
have massive
tangible meaningful benefits for
connective tissue but there's some
mechanistic stuff that indicates okay
there might be something to it
uh but the reason that i singled out
glycine um
there there was uh a pretty solid review
by
melendez hevia and colleagues in 2019
where they kind of made the case that
you know
glycine is probably a little bit short
of what would be
optimal in terms of uh you know
maximizing
all of its roles in the body including
collagen synthesis
and i think for a good analogy to kind
of help
wrap your head around the concept we
talk about protein all the time right
and so with dietary protein there's the
number
that prevents you from having clinical
deficiency
right so like what is the what is the
minimum amount of protein per day that
prevents you from having health
consequences from insufficient protein
that's a very different number from how
much protein should a lifter
eat every day to maximize their gains
right those are very very different
numbers
and very very different concepts and so
what they argue
in this review paper generally speaking
is yes we can synthesize glycine so it's
not
classically considered an essential
amino amino acid right it's considered
non-essential
um but what they argue is when you put
together the maximum
amount we can really synthesize per day
and you put together the amount from the
typical diet maybe you get 1.5 to 3
grams per day
maybe you synthesize about 3 grams per
day of glycine
what they argue is after you put those
together
you still might be falling maybe around
10 grams short
of what they they would suggest would be
optimal in terms of really making sure
you've got enough glycine to maximize
you know
what it's responsible for in the body so
so they argue that there's this deficit
at
maybe 10 even 12 grams per day i think
they argue at some points
in the paper so the idea is even though
glycine is not considered an essential
amino acid
potentially increasing your intake via
supplementation
might be advisable um and and
theoretically this would probably do
much of what we would
expect uh collagen or gelatin
supplementation to do
the big caveat or i guess one of the
reasons that you might explore this
instead of the catch-all approach of you
just throwing everything at it from
gelatin or collagen
so there is theoretically
cause for concern about kidney stones
when you're taking in
high doses of hydroxyproline which is
one of the components of gelatin and
collagen
the studies that have used gelatin and
collagen supplementation have not
identified that as an adverse effect
it's not like
participants in all these studies are
getting kidney stones all over the place
i haven't seen that reported at all but
theoretically when you look at you know
the biochemistry underlying that
metabolism you could say hey
if you're kind of if you have a history
of kidney stones or it's something that
you're really watchful of
maybe high dose of doses of
hydroxyproline wouldn't be advisable
i'm just going to throw another
practical consideration out there
if they're saying that you might need up
to 10 grams of additional glycine
and glycine is like what around a third
of collagen you'd have to supplement
with like 30 grams of collagen per day
which again if you've supplemented with
collagen before
which i have that's not uh
that's not a trivial amount of collagen
to choke down
because like it's it's bulk forming
so you know you mix some in water it
absorbs a lot of the water
uh you know it basically starts becoming
jello
um and so either you need to consume
uh just an enormous amount of water
which will still end up having like a
really
really weird and in my opinion
off-putting texture
to choke it all down or you could you
know mix it with like 20 ounces of water
and a shaker cup
uh start drinking it and like as you're
drinking it it will keep
absorbing water and like by the end of
it you'd have to be eating it with a
spoon
um so anyway supplementing with 30 grams
of
collagen or hydro or
gelatin or hydrolyzed collagen i mean
it's theoretically possible it's not
like it tastes as bad
uh as um like sodium bicarbonate or
something like that
but it's in my opinion pretty unpleasant
yeah so if if you're trying to get 10
grams of glycine
it's probably way more just generally
pleasant
to supplement with the glycine than to
supplement with the gelatin or collagen
in my opinion yeah and i should be super
clear that you know when we talk about
this 10 gram number
of of glycine it's critical to
understand where that number came from
it was not a randomized controlled study
where 10 grams of glycine did something
good
it was biochemistry calculations
you know so that number should
inherently be taken with a grain of salt
uh so so i don't want it to seem like
i'm saying yeah i mean one weird trick
get 10 grams of glycine every day it's
this is very speculative this is more
calculation based more than anything
um but in terms of like what kind of
doses are actually tolerable for glycine
uh you look at some studies there have
been people who
take nine grams on an empty stomach and
report some
abdominal pain and some soft stools
which isn't pleasant
so that's probably not a great route to
go but
there have been studies where they've
given five grams of glycine
with a meal three times per day so 15
grams total
and in that study that i'm thinking of
there were no major adverse events it
seemed like it was pretty well tolerated
so
if this is an idea that you think is
interesting
i always encourage people before you do
something weird and kind of experimental
with supplementation
run it by a doctor or registered
dietitian to see if they think it's
right for you before you just start kind
of
taking all sorts of weird potions and
powders
but but there is at least evidence to
suggest that doses as high as 15 grams a
day
can be tolerated if they're timed
appropriately um
so you know the question comes back to
you know that headline from that study
of glycine
having huge impacts on collagen
synthesis
is there anything to it i think
mechanistically yes
is there evidence to suggest that it's
going to have major positive impacts on
anything related to lifting in terms of
the actual integrity or
you know biomechanical properties of
connective tissues we don't have that
evidence do we have any evidence that it
reduces injury occurrence or enhances
recovery from soft
uh or from connective tissue injury no
we don't have that evidence
uh so at now i kind of at this point i
kind of file it under the interesting
idea
category like oh there's some
mechanistic stuff there there's some
rodent stuff there
um will it pan out i don't know
so if you're someone who's really
interested in it there's enough meat on
the bone to to find it fascinating
and to think hey maybe we will
eventually have some evidence to suggest
that
you know maybe instead of the the the
modest
positive effects we've seen with
collagen or gelatin supplementation
maybe it's the glycine that that's
really pulling a lot of that load
um we're not really certain yet but but
but the fact that there was that in
vitro study
uh with with the pretty crazy numbers
that that seem pretty uh
pretty extreme you know take the numbers
from an in vitro study always with a
grain of salt but is there a mechanism
there that makes sense i would say
definitely and the final caveat to put
to throw in here is collagen synthesis
is not necessarily going to be
determinant of
you know how your tendons and ligaments
respond
to loading right so when it comes to
trying to put yourself in a position to
reduce your likelihood of tendon or
ligament injury or
trying to come back from connective
tissue injuries
yes nutrition has a role but training
and loading
have a role as well and so even if we
have a study saying oh wow look at this
mechanistic
uh you know look at this increase in
collagen synthesis we've observed
you would still want to see research
indicating that not only is collagen
being synthesized but
we're actually because there is collagen
breakdown as well so we want to make
sure that there is
net accretion of collagen but also that
the collagen is being
constructed with adequate architecture
to actually positively affect
the biomechanical properties of that
connective tissue because if there's
just more more collagen with poor
architecture of the collagen fibers it
might not necessarily
pan out to better recovery or even
injury prevention
for that tissue so uh if you are someone
who's concerned about
uh the integrity of your connective
tissues tendon and ligament specifically
keith barr has put out some really good
practical papers
of like hey here's like an idea of what
you ought to be doing from a training
perspective
uh here's what you ought to be doing
from a nutrition perspective i think he
gives a pretty clear
pretty fair rundown of what we know and
what we don't know
and so i'll be sure to link some of
those resources in the show notes but
keith barr has done some really cool
innovative work when it comes to
collagen and gelatin type
supplementation
and he really knows his stuff when it
comes to tendon and ligament but
one of the one of the interesting things
he advocates is these small little
exercise bouts throughout the day
so when he talks about training for
either injury prevention or recovery
from these type of tendon or ligament
issues
he talks about doing these little little
bits of activity less than 10 minutes in
duration
but doing them at least six hours apart
from each other
and so doing three of those really tiny
sessions
throughout the the day breakfast or not
breakfast morning
afternoon and evening and in the links i
share he kind of talks about the
mechanistic underpinning for why that is
and kind of the
the the time course of the refractory
response to loading that's observed in
some of these tissues but
um you know it's one of those topics
when we talk about
trying to beneficially impact
tendon and ligament there's a lot of
interest there there's a lot of
mechanistic research but
i'd really love to see more
applied interventions where we really
try to
get a big sample of people in there and
see how these things pan out when we
you know take it from a petri dish and
then say okay
we're in the real world now training
nutrition does this stuff
actually impact injury rates or impact
recovery
but for now that's really all i can
share about it um
it's it's a bit speculative but it's
certainly fascinating
okay let's go ahead and move on to a q a
segment um
we intended to do a bunch of q and a's
last episode but we ran out of time and
we could only talk about
what wilkes score ant-man would have
which i think a lot of people got
benefit from
you know let me let me comment on that
real quick
uh a few people responded to that
segment
saying that i actually got it completely
wrong wow
and that the way ant-man's powers work
are
that basically they they make his uh
atoms
further apart or closer together and
that's how he grows
and or shrinks and therefore mass would
be conserved
uh and you know getting bigger smaller
wouldn't change his mass and
therefore wouldn't affect his wilkes
score all i can say to that
is that's [ __ ] [ __ ] because i've
seen the documentary film ant-man
and the follow-up documentary film
ant-man and the wasp
uh and you can see no camera tricks the
camera follows him the whole time
he's like riding on ants and
i i realize that ants have just insane
strength to body weight ratios but like
paul rudd
let's just assume he's like 170 180 if
he
sits on an ant even if he's shrunk down
he's gonna crush the ant
the fact that he can ride on an ant
inherently means that his mass is
decreasing
wow so i think hank pym is full of [ __ ]
fake news
uh and i mean trust your eyes folks like
if he can ride on an ant his
mass is decreasing yeah i couldn't ride
on an ant i definitely couldn't
wow that's we may have uncovered a major
plot hole uh which really blows the lid
we might be
this is as big of a deal as when people
figured out that the moon landing was
fake
yeah this could be quite a scandal um
we'll have to touch base about this
again in the future but for now
uh let's talk about other stuff so um
this question came from someone who said
who says their name is
natty and uh in parentheses they said
this is my actual nickname
i'm unfortunately 100 serious
um so the question is greg can you
rank cooking methods from best to worst
in terms of how they impact
micronutrient content for example
i primarily cook my potatoes in the
microwave and i'd like to know if it
would be better to cook them differently
such as
baking them in an oven pan frying them
boiling them etc sure so
um it's hard to give like a generalized
answer to this question because it
depends a lot on
like what nutrient you're talking about
specifically so
uh but just kind of to paint and broad
strokes
in a general sense uh cooking your food
does tend to increase nutritional value
relative to eating it raw that's not the
case for
all potential foods and all potential
nutrients but that's like a general
trend
so yeah in general cooking food is
a good thing to do um
and really the only two things you you
need to watch out for
a lot uh are one just like completely
cooking the [ __ ] out of your food
so like getting it really hot cooking it
for a really really long time
that can cause some vitamins to break
down
um so yeah you don't want to cook it
i mean basically you just don't want to
cook it to death uh and then the other
thing
is that um frying and boiling or
poaching foods can
decrease nutritional value to some
degree so
uh like vitamins minerals other
nutrients can leach out
into the frying oil and or water
um which if you're not planning on
consuming those things which
you know maybe you're you're boiling
something and then you're gonna like
reduce the water down and do something
with that if so cool
if you're planning on consuming the fry
oil that's a problem
uh i wouldn't recommend that anyway
um but yeah so so frying and boiling
like
some some nutrients can leach out into
the water or oil
uh but other than that like pretty much
every other cooking method
is fine and like fairly comparable from
a perspective of maintaining
micronutrients
uh one other general thing i'll say
about cooking methods just to be aware
of
is that when it comes to cooking meat
from a general health perspective
it's probably a good idea to cook it
gently so
like baking it or like braising it
or something like that there's some
evidence
that uh putting a really really hard
sear on it
can increase your risk of some like
metabolic disorders
um so i mean on one hand that's very
unfortunate because getting a good sear
on
say like a chicken thigh or a good piece
of steak or like a good piece of pork
is very delicious um but anyway you know
like everything about nutrition is
kind of a balancing act of uh satisfying
your hedonic desires with
you know trying to make it generally
healthy so i would say if you're like
food prepping stuff
uh and you're cooking meat try to cook
it pretty gently but you know if you're
having a meal that you are cooking for
the sake of it being delicious
uh you know maybe once or twice a week
yeah go ahead and put a hard sear on it
but
i wouldn't recommend that being how you
cook your meat all the time
alright so luke asks eric uh
if strength and size gains come back
relatively quickly after a cut
parentheses assuming this is true based
on my own experience but feel free to
lambast me if this is
indeed a false premise close parentheses
is there any benefit
to cutting at a less conservative pace
in order to spend a higher percentage of
the year
in a lean bulking phase this is a very
good question
um starting out i'm going to leave
strength out of it
just because of all the neuromuscular
aspects involved there
i want to keep it kind of just in the
realm of body composition because i
think it's most directly related to the
question here
so the question basically is should i
speed up my
cut so i can get back into a bulking
phase and ultimately
you know positively influence
lean mass accretion over time um
the first part that i would push back
against is
we have to be a little bit cautious
about how aggressively we lose weight
um there's a balancing act of course we
want to make
positive strides toward the goal so we
don't want to
say that slower is always better
you know because at a certain point if
if you're losing weight slow enough
you're essentially not losing weight it
would just take forever
but the downside of going super
aggressive
uh with a cutting phase is that it is
probably
gonna lead to more loss of lean tissue
and so
if the whole point of speeding it up is
so we can get into a bulk it doesn't
really make sense to lose
excessive lean mass just so we can get
back into a lean mass buildings phase i
think
we want to be mindful of maintaining as
much lean mass as we can
during a fat loss phase the second thing
that i would push back against a little
bit
is the idea that um you know lean body
mass or muscle mass
rebounds very quickly after
a weight loss attempt or after weight
loss is basically ended and you
transition back into a caloric surplus
um so this was a a really fun study that
that we did when i was in grad school
but but we studied the initial
changes in body composition after
physique competition so bodybuilding and
physique categories
and so what we found was initially after
competition there's
obviously some quick weight gain within
the first few days
which is almost exclusively a whole
bunch of water and glycogen coming back
um not really much in terms of real lean
tissue
and really not much in terms of fat
because you you have to be in a hell of
a surplus for two days to meaningfully
uh you know accrue a lot of fat tissue i
mean there's a caloric content
associated with putting on fat
uh so in a few days after a diet we see
a whole bunch of water and glycogen come
back but then we're pretty much at a
stable
steady state but what was really uh kind
of discouraging about it
was within those first four to six weeks
after competition
there does appear to be a preferential
regain of fat mass
rather than fat free mass which is an
ideal and it kind of goes against
i remember when i first got into lifting
and nutrition and stuff
everybody would be like dude after a fat
loss phase
you are primed for growth and you're
just gonna put on muscle
so rapidly you're never going to believe
it and
the the evidence doesn't support that
whether we're looking at lean people or
obese people trained or untrained
what we do see is a preferential regain
of fat in the initial
uh transition from a diet to a caloric
surplus
yeah there are a lot of people who still
say that too yeah i
i get it i i get why on the surface
level that seems like an appealing
hypothesis
but you know the the empirical evidence
doesn't support it
and when you really dig into the
theoretical rationale it doesn't make
sense
um just because putting on a bunch of
lean mass from a biological perspective
doesn't gain you much it doesn't afford
you much
uh when it comes to being resilient to
future
caloric deficits um you know you're
basically putting on this tissue that's
calorically expensive to maintain uh
and not a very good source of energy if
needed
you know during a prolonged uh energy
deficit so
even if you want to get back to kind of
evolutionary theoretical routes of why
we would regain weight after a diet
it doesn't really make sense to get out
of a prolonged surplus and say
sweet let's put on a bunch of muscle
tissue or organ tissue
get out of a prolonged deficit yes yeah
sorry
um but yeah so i would push back against
both of those things no
that is a good point and i never thought
of it that way before like
if we just assume physiology makes sense
as like my undergrad physiology
professor was very fond of saying
uh yeah i mean like humanity developed
in
like periods of cyclical famines so like
yeah you you get [ __ ] shredded uh
which
you know entails basically like being at
a low level of starvation for a long
period of time
uh and you know your body doesn't
function that much differently than it
did when we lived on the savannah
uh and it's like yeah okay like you came
very very close to starvation like i can
tell that because you're like [ __ ]
four percent body fat uh
so obviously like famine is a threat
that exists in this organism's
environment
and so like yeah what's it gonna do when
there are calories again
is it going to put on fat so that like
the next famine which your body should
suspect is around the corner because you
just experienced one
should we put on fat to be able to cope
with that or like
just say [ __ ] that like one famine
happened
what are the odds that another one is
ever going to happen let's get [ __ ]
huge
for like all of all of the ladies on the
savannah like
no that's that's ridiculous yeah
you when you reason your way through it
it doesn't really make sense
on a deeper level and it's also why you
have to be really cautious about the
overly simplistic
kind of mechanistic approach to
physiology so like
i i'm sure there's probably i don't know
12 million articles out there that
probably say like oh after a cut
you know insulin sensitivity is through
the roof which is going to
shuttle all those beautiful nutrients to
your muscle tissue and you're going to
explode
you know and put on all this muscle
really rapidly
where else does insulin shuttle
nutrients to
just as far as i know literally nowhere
or maybe fat cells but yeah like
you'll see people who take like a little
granule of a mechanism and be like wait
a minute
fat loss increased insulin sensitivity
shuttle stuff toward muscle
you're probably going to get absolutely
huge and gain no fat
but it's like that that doesn't seem to
pan out it doesn't seem to be the way it
works
yeah um yeah like you said that little
pesky thing that
you know also fat cells like that too um
that that's something to deal with
but um so there's a couple things to
keep in mind there
um when it comes down to this
theoretical idea of
a super fat fast cut and then
transitioning
to uh you know to get a quick rebound of
muscle gain
so my preferred approach because a lot
of people have these goals in mind right
a lot of people do bulk and cut cycles
and a lot of people
want to spend the majority of the time
building muscle but also being at a body
fat level they feel good about
and i think a preferred approach to that
is we want to minimize the loss
of lean mass or fat free mass that
occurs during the cut
instead of banking on a big rebound and
kind of
assuming we're going to gain some quick
muscle when we transition out of the
diet
so a conservative rate of weight loss is
going to be great for minimizing that
loss
of fat-free mass but you know i
do encourage people to minimize the time
that they spend cutting especially early
in their lifting career
so you know what i generally encourage
people to do is instead of speeding up
your cut
get to a body fat that you're happy with
with a nice
conservative rate of weight loss so just
cut once and do it right get down to a
body fat where
where you feel good in terms of your
health your performance your body image
for whatever reason you're cutting get
down to a body fat that makes sense
long term and then bulk from there
transition into a muscle building phase
and be committed to that bulk
for the long haul um you know basically
say okay i'm happy with this body fat
i'm going to take my time with it i'm
not going to be super aggressive in that
early
rebound phase because like i said
preferentially you're probably more
likely to quickly gain fat rather than
quickly gain muscle
so it's a slow cut and then a nice
gradual bulk where you're not eating at
you know
enormous surplus get yourself a good 2
3 400 calorie surplus do some solid
resistance training gauge your rate of
weight gain from there
and move forward but what i really
encourage people to avoid
is getting stuck in what i call the the
wheel spinning zone
which is basically rapid cut rapid bulk
rapid cut rapid bulk
losing fat free mass during these rapid
cuts doing these rapid bulks and
initially preferentially regaining fat
mass
i can't think of a worse way to do it is
basically oscillating back and forth
between extreme cuts and extreme bulks
uh unequivocally the worst way you could
possibly do it from my perspective
if you're drug-free i should
there should be like a banner that just
runs across the screen
whenever for all content that i'm
speaking about with physiology that just
says
assuming you're drug free because like
you throw drugs into the mix we can fix
every problem yeah like i i'm sure
people
are gonna if we didn't give that caveat
someone would tweet us like
that famous off-season picture of dennis
wolfe and just be like
yeah where's your god now like yeah got
[ __ ] huge
you know that's been one of the one of
the great things about um
metabolic adaptation is i talk about it
a lot i write about it a lot
and i'm always kind of under the
assumption we're talking about drug free
not because i give a damn about people
taking drugs but
my background is in publishing
peer-reviewed research
you're not just going to throw out in a
peer-reviewed paper like well i don't
know are you on trend
like that's not how we that's not how we
study physiology
in sports science is like you know
footnote by the way if you're on trend
ignore this
so like every now and then
oh man like so you'll occasionally see
in limitation
like limitation sections like uh you
know
all of our subjects purported to be drug
free but like you know we didn't have
the funding to drug test all of them so
like do without what you will
if there was a reverse of that where
it's like uh
you know we had drug-free subjects we
don't know whether these
results generalized to other populations
such as youth elderly or people on like
four grams a year
if if they just started treating that as
like a special population that like
maybe research doesn't generalize to
doesn't pertain to
aggressive insulin abuse um
but no so like i i get in the habit of
just kind of assuming that's the
standard caveat and then like someone
will ask me a question about like
so what happens with metabolic
adaptation if i'm taking
these 11 drugs and i'm like oh well then
you solved all of it
and then you're fine like you have
pharmacologically altered
everything i just spoke about so like i
don't know it's probably fine but where
am i going to find the research to
validate that yeah
one of one of the problems with
prolonged deficits might be a decrease
in testosterone levels
if you're putting like a gram and a half
of test into your system every week
congratulations you don't have problems
with testosterone levels
yeah like taking testosterone levels
thyroid hormones thermogenics that are
way more potent than thyroid hormones
like you know everything else so yeah
that's certainly a big caveat to keep in
mind
okay uh moving on uh this one is from
a user who goes by the name of one quick
trick and the question is
what is the role of flywheel training
strictly for hypertrophy
if it has a positive effect should it be
used as an adjunct
training method or should we ditch
conventional weight training and use
flywheel
training instead uh yeah so
um the research that exists to this
point
comparing flywheel training to just kind
of like more conventional resistance
training
basically finds that the effects are
similar uh with regards to both strength
and hypertrophy
there was a i believe meta analysis that
came out something like three or four
years ago
um that made it look like fro flywheel
training was just like
the next evolution of resistance
training
they were like look compared to other
forms of training it makes you
super jacked super strong uh and it
turns out that the people who did it
just like
um completely
misrepresented or botched their
inclusion criteria and included
a bunch of training or like several
studies that compared flywheel training
to
no training turns out it's a lot better
than no training
but like when you pull all that together
and like write it up
as if you're comparing it against like
conventional training
it's not completely accurate anyways so
the stuff that does
actually compare flywheel training
against like conventional resistance
training
tends to find similar strength gains
similar hypertrophy
um doesn't seem to be better doesn't
seem to be worse doesn't seem to be
particularly special
which checks out like it makes sense
like ultimately
you know you're you're trying to uh
stress the muscle
and put enough tension on it to provoke
a hypertrophic response
and you can do that with flywheel
training um so yeah like
it's fine um i would say
that uh there are distinct pros and cons
of flywheel training compared to just
like conventional resistance training
one of the pros or really like the
biggest pro by far
is that it takes up way way less space
so um
you know if you don't want to go to the
gym or like
can't go to the gym for some reason and
you don't have
a whole room in your home that you can
dedicate to a home gym setup
and you just get like a flywheel device
it's gonna take up way way less space
so that's a huge plus you can make it
work in pretty much
any living situation um
so that's good uh a con though is that
you do have to be
kind of creative for some exercises you
want to do so like lower body training
very simple and straightforward uh
there's like a little handle attachment
that comes with pretty much any flywheel
device that you could use for deadlifts
rdls
you can get like a harness that you can
clip the the cord to
to do squats like something that would
feel very similar to a belt squat
so that's good pulling exercises like
rose
very straightforward easy to do um same
thing with like
biceps training but uh like training
pressing exercises or training uh like
triceps uh
not nearly as straightforward like you
would need to get kind of creative to
make it work
um and also like
you're you're limited
in exercise variety to some degree
so you know i think that you know
simply exposing your muscles to an
appropriate stimulus and being
consistent with it
is probably the biggest not just
probably it's for sure the biggest and
most important thing for
getting stronger building muscle but if
you're
a really really advanced trainee who's
like you know
maybe trying to get some marginal gains
in
like regional hypertrophy by including
more exercise variety in your training
that's going to be a lot more
challenging if all you have access to is
a flywheel device
uh so what what i would say is that um
i still think that like you know
probably the best way to
maximize hypertrophy if you're
like a reasonably advanced lifter
is to get a gym membership and you know
be able to use all of the equipment that
would be available to you
if you're someone who's you know brand
new to lifting or maybe like early
intermediate i
definitely think you can get the job
done with flywheel training and get
pretty similar
results to what you'd get with free
weights and another thing that i would
say
is one of the things that we've talked
about several times
since uh gym closure started with covet
19
is you can do really really solid
upper body training with either just
body weight or
very very limited equipment but lower
body training is
a lot more challenging to do without
some sort of external resistance
and lower body training is very very
easy to do with a flywheel device
so if you're someone who you know either
can't go back
to the gym for a while or just doesn't
want to and you don't have room in your
apartment for like a full home gym
setup or your house for a full home gym
setup
uh just doing like bodyweight training
for upper body and getting a flywheel
device for lower body training would be
a
great way to approach training from like
a very minimalist perspective
um so anyway yeah like in general i
think it's fine i don't think it's
notably better or worse for most people
in most
circumstances so uh
john luca asks eric is it necessary to
cycle caffeine for its ergogenic effects
if cycling is necessary how often should
i
cycle it and for how long you know this
topic i
saw it in the the inbox and i could have
sworn we had talked about it before but
i couldn't find it so i figured for good
measure
might as well hit the highlights again
because it is a question that gets asked
all the time and greg please do feel
free to
interject and correct me or interrupt me
because i'm largely
using an article you wrote for mass as
kind of the basis here
for much of the answer but you wrote a
great study back in the day
it's probably probably a couple years
ago at this point right
uh yeah i think it might have been
volume one yeah so um
that was back in in the it was really
awful for a while there i wasn't part of
mass
and then the readers had to put up with
that and live through that phase
a lot of good articles of that time
frame but but yeah it's kind of a a dark
part of mass's history
is the fact that i wasn't initially
involved with it but
back before i became part of the team uh
you reviewed a study by
laura and colleagues in 2019 um
and it was called time course of
tolerance to the performance benefits of
caffeine
and the really nice thing about this
study was they actually addressed the
question directly
which is kind of not the case for this
research question so
a lot of studies that try to make
inferences about
do we habituate to the effects of
caffeine
they'll recruit people and say hey do
you do you consume caffeine a lot or not
and kind of divide them into groups the
people who consume plenty and the people
who don't
and then they'll test some performance
outcome in response to caffeine and say
okay
did the responses look different when we
compared the people who typically
consume caffeine to people who are
caffeine naive
so that's kind of the approach most
studies take because it's
a lot easier and less labor intensive
and resource intensive
um but it doesn't really directly affect
address a question that is longitudinal
in nature
which is basically if we continue keep
uh taking it
does the effect become diminished or
even fully wear off
over time and i've often said you know
like
there was a time there where i flirted
with the
idea of being a professor and going and
starting a lab
and without question like i had a short
list of studies that i'd want to do
right out of the gate
and this is a question that i think we
have a lot to learn about i think
it would be very easy to set up a study
where you looked at
really frequent testing on like a
dynamometer looking at
muscle force output um over
a long series of not just habituation to
caffeine but i'm also interested in
learning more about
the time course of withdrawal and
re-sensitization
right so what do you think your dropout
rate on that study would be
a million percent uh
i don't know it's theoretical i don't
have to worry about these logistical
considerations greg
uh i took a different job as you know
but but no like we really would benefit
from having more longitudinal studies
where you know we do an exercise
intervention that's lo you know
not going to induce a lot of soreness so
we can do it frequently
but get an idea of specifically looking
at
strength related outcomes or power
related outcomes
you know how quickly do we habituate
what kind of withdrawal symptoms do we
see in the days after we remove caffeine
uh and then what's the time course of
becoming
re-sensitized to to caffeine you know so
do you have to abstain for three days or
three weeks
to kind of get back it to the point
where you maximize your response
a lot of those questions we don't have
really good answers to
but what they found in the study by
laura and colleagues was there was some
modest
tolerance that was developed over about
a 20-day period
and they used a variety of different
performance outcomes so some were
aerobic
i think one was like a high-intensity
cycling i don't think they used anything
that would really mimic resistance
training
but it did show that there was a general
um
a general appearance of tolerance
developing but
the the fact that the the magnitude of
the effect diminished a little bit at
certain points in the timeline
doesn't mean that the effect completely
disappeared and that's really important
to keep in mind it wasn't like
yeah you get to use caffeine for 11 days
and then you're screwed and it doesn't
work anymore
yeah and to note like that study ran for
a month
um and so it's entirely possible
that if people you know continued using
caffeine every day
for a year like maybe
full tolerance would develop but also
like using a fixed amount
of a substance every day for a month is
like a pretty long time for tolerance to
develop one would think
uh and so like basically what they found
is that the ergogenic effects of
caffeine
over the course of about a month were
decreased by like maybe 50 60 percent
give or take and i don't think it's
completely crazy to assume that that
would
basically extend out into perpetuity uh
it may or may not but i do sort of
suspect that a month
is plenty of time for people to develop
the amount of tolerance that they're
going to develop
yeah and another thing to keep in mind i
talked about how there were
limitations to the more standard
approach to this question which is just
grouping
habitual users versus non-users but that
doesn't mean we can't get some
inferences
from those studies and with those
studies
generally speaking they tend to indicate
that whether you're
naive to caffeine or a habitual user
we still see pretty similar ergogenic
effects among those groups
and so when you triangulate that
evidence
it looks like some tolerance or some
habituation might occur
but it that's very different from saying
that the
ergogenic effect entirely disappears
so if you're someone who's worried about
this tolerance developing
and you want to really make sure you're
maximizing your use of caffeine there's
a few different options that you have
the first option is just to not worry
about it because
regular caffeine users seem to pretty
reliably have
ergogenic responses to caffeine so
that's a very simple
straightforward way to approach it
another option if you're really worried
about it still
is to just only use caffeine when you
need it you know so if you only use it
here and there maybe a couple workouts
per week you're probably not going to
develop a great deal
of tolerance or habituation to that
because of how intermittent
your caffeine use is and then another
option would be if you want to every now
and then maybe take a week or two off of
caffeine use to
to just restore that sensitivity and you
know
if i was someone who was really worried
about it and wanted to
incorporate that into a typical training
schedule
it could be as simple as just saying hey
during your deload no caffeine
right so then you're going to do a block
of training and maybe there's a little
tolerance that develops over time
but if you're kind of taking
the downside of caffeine abstention
during your deload you're probably not
really losing anything in the trade-off
there aside from
you know maybe a slightly less present
less pleasant deload week but
i would say that would be another option
is to just kind of strategically
i mean would you think that maybe a week
or two off would be
sufficient in order to kind of restore
some of that uh
sensitivity i would think uh i mean
the handful of times that i that i have
tried to go off caffeine
day one sucks day two sucks but a little
less
by like day three or four i feel pretty
normal um so yeah
i think a week would be plenty but i i
mean obviously i'm not like
testing performance every day across
that time but in terms of like
uh psychological withdrawal symptoms
they seem to be gone within a week so i
kind of assume that like physiological
like performance withdrawal is would be
done within a week and so like
sensitivity would come back
i don't know if that's true or not but
but that's how i feel in my heart
sometimes science is more about feeling
than knowing you know
i do wonder so when we first started
hanging out
uh you were kind of busy you
often consume caffeine i wonder if at
any point during that time if you just
went cold turkey
i wonder if you would have been
hospitalized by the withdrawal symptoms
i doubt it um i would i've just never
seen anyone so
so fully dependent on caffeine yeah
so um if i ever did have like a chill
weekend
uh which was uncommon but like sometimes
it happened
uh i would i would occasionally go
without caffeine like on a saturday
um and honestly i gotta say
i don't get that bad of withdrawal
symptoms from caffeine like
uh i'll start developing a headache
around three or four pm
take an advil goes away uh i do feel
like more lethargic and less focused but
honestly like even when i'm using uh
probably inadvisable amounts of caffeine
if i go off it for a day like it's
really really not
that bad that's good yeah
okay so we've got a couple questions
that got upvoted a lot in the reddit
subgroup
we only have time to get to one of them
this episode but we absolutely guarantee
next episode we'll get the other one
right so so the first one
uh that we're going to answer it's our
final q a for the day
it's by pavlovian uh that's the username
and the question is i'm curious about
what the literature has to say on the
subject of
trigger points or muscle knots i've
heard a variety of things on the subject
ranging from
they are the root of every muscular pain
issue to
they don't exist anecdotally i've
personally had a number of times over
the years where applying some rather
intense
self massage to areas with a tender
tense spot in a muscle
has provided some dramatic and lasting
pain relief
what does the literature say are trigger
points real
or have i been duped by big placebo
yeah so uh first things first over in
the
stronger by science subreddit uh jason
our on staff physical therapist and uh
my buddy nathan jones who's also a
physical therapist
both have already given very very good
answers to this question in the
subreddit if you would like to check
them out
um and what i'm gonna say
isn't all that much different from what
they said
but uh hey you know uh
podcast is a different means of
communication than reddit so
uh answer it here as well so first off
i'm gonna address the question of
people claiming that they're the root of
every muscular pain
issue that's obviously ridiculous
sometimes you strain a muscle too hard
and tear it off the bone
you know that's not a trigger point
sometimes
uh you get in a fight with a jilted
ex-lover and they
chop through a muscle with a machete you
can't chalk that up to
to muscle knots or trigger points so
like obviously there are
roots of muscular pain issues that go
beyond this
so absolutely ridiculous premise um
but to to actually answer the question
like what are trigger points
do they exist do they matter uh and
for that i think it depends how you
define like a must
a muscular knot or a trigger point um
and there are
various specific definitions that people
use from time to time so
uh one of the common ones that people
will talk about is
myofascial adhesions it's the idea that
um like basically the the fascia that
surrounds and runs through the muscle uh
will kind of like
get stuck together almost so um like
fibers and fascicles can't slide past
each other the way that
one would want them to and that like
forms a knot
and my understanding is that that can
theoretically happen
and like one of one of the reasons
actually that like range of motion tends
to decrease with age
is that like collagenous tissues
um do kind of like grow outgrowths and
like stick to each other more
so like that's something that can
theoretically happen but i don't
know the relevance of it on kind of like
a small micro
scale uh in like healthy younger people
um the other kind of mechanistic
explanation or like definition for
trigger points that i see people put
forth from time to time
is that it's like a local ischemic
crisis
so basically uh in a small region of the
muscle
blood flow might become restricted and
then
like due to that ischemia the tissue
becomes inflamed
and then it swells a little bit and that
can further cut off blood flow
uh and then they term this an energy
crisis where it basically feeds into
itself you get some ischemia you get
some inflammation
that causes more ischemia that causes
more inflammation
etc etc um and my understanding is that
there is actually
some evidence that that can exist where
basically like when they do
uh identify like very very well-defined
trigger points in some individuals they
can go in there and like
you know basically study that tissue and
see if there are like signs and symptoms
of ischemia and like sometimes there is
but
the question is you know that
maybe can theoretically happen but is
that the case in
every knot or trigger point in the human
body
i would think probably not like you know
maybe that's like a root cause of some
of them but i i doubt
that's like a universalized phenomenon
another thing just to note about trigger
points
is that uh
if you go to like a massage therapist or
some or something and they say like ah
you have a lot of knots you have a lot
of trigger points
like you probably do because like
everyone does
um but also you shouldn't put like
too terribly much stock in their like
specifically diagnosed
trigger points where like they point out
to you where where they all are
um there's some research looking at the
uh inner rater reliability
of identifying muscle knots and trigger
points
and it's really bad um so
you know one person who's theoretically
an expert
feels your muscles like finds some tight
spots uh
kind of like marks where they are or
like identifies where they are and then
like
another person does the same thing maybe
they find a couple of the same ones
maybe they find some different ones
but very very poor inner raider
reliability um
so anyway it's it's a phenomenon that
does exist um
but it's like it's kind of it's kind of
a slippery phenomenon
i suppose uh and i think it makes the
most sense
to simply think about it as a sensory
phenomenon
um because that very much clears up the
question of whether they exist or not
like
do you have small spots in your muscle
that feel tight
feel uncomfortable and feel tender if
you put pressure on them
like yes everyone does what's the cause
of them
is it an ischemic energy crisis is it
myofascial adhesions
who gives a [ __ ] i personally don't give
a [ __ ]
uh and i think the the ultimate question
is
um you know if if they exist
and if i'm defining them as just like a
sensory phenomenon of like an area of
muscle that feels uncomfortable they do
exist you know then the question is like
what can you do about them and like you
know is it
worthwhile to kind of try to massage
them out or like roll around on a foam
roller
or lacrosse ball and i think like the
most
simple straightforward answer is like if
it helps you feel better
then like sure do it um you know
and maybe it gives you lasting relief
which
uh the the story pavlovian recounted
sounds like it did uh it did and has
caused him like
some lasting relief and so that's good
if it doesn't and it's one of those
things where like
you know maybe you just have a knot that
occurs in your hamstrings
all the time and if you spend like two
minutes working on it before a workout
it goes away and your workout feels
better
like whatever two minutes of like
maintenance work before a workout that's
fine you can do that
um if it's one of those things where
like
you have a lot of knots that are super
uncomfortable
and either take like a super long time
to work out
before you can start training or they're
like causing a lot of discomfort
and significantly impacting your quality
of life you know go to a professional
about that like hit up a physical
therapist see if they can do anything
for it
um yeah i mean in terms of like do they
exist
and what can you do about them like yeah
they probably exist and if you do
something and it feels good
keep doing it um yeah i think that
the uh i i basically think they've been
mythologized too much um
and and it's it's one of those things
where like if there's something that you
can do a little something to give
yourself some
relief help you feel better that's nice
uh and if it
becomes a problem that you can't manage
on your own
seek uh seek professional help
that sounds reasonable now to play us
out we aren't we're at the end of the
episode here
um i'm gonna be honest i'm looking at
the outline
i have no idea where you're going with
this so i will just
present it and and i will excitedly
follow along
so carsonization um
go yeah so uh i learned about this
recently
and uh i had never heard of it but it's
like
a crazy example of convergent evolution
so
convergent evolution is the idea that
like if something
generally works from like a darwinian
fitness perspective
it might evolve you know similarly over
time so
a good example of that is among the
mammals like
placentals and marsupials were separated
like all of the marsupials were in
australia the placentals were elsewhere
but like there are a lot of very similar
uh placental and marsupial animals that
evolved completely separately but like
the evolutions they
evolved like helped them fill some sort
of like ecological niche
um you know like mammals and fish
evolving to swim
so you know well fish evolving to swim
first and then like mammals winding up
with like similar adaptations like
whales and dolphins like
you know the like tails to flip water
out of the way and like create pressure
differentials to move through the water
like
yeah it works like that's that's
convergent evolution
anyway so carsonization is the concept
of convergent evolution in crabs
and it's crazy because like a lot of the
crabs out there in the world
aren't actually crabs so there there is
uh like a phylum of crabs
true crabs and that's like most of the
crabs you would come across
but the general crab shape has evolved
at least
five different times so one of them was
the true crabs
um i i think uh
what's it called decapodal arthropods
like
arthropods with like tin appendages two
of them being claws
so like true crabs that's like the the
largest group of them
but then the hairy stone crab
is another very crab looking thing that
did not evolve
along with crabs it evolved from another
arthropod
porcelain crabs that's there's like a
whole group of them there's like
10 or 12 different types of porcelain
crabs look just like crabs
they're not actually crabs um king crabs
this was the one that freaked me out so
like
uh if you've ever eaten crab legs you've
probably either eaten snow crab which
is an actual crab it's a true crab or
some sort of king crab
probably the red king crab that's i
think what most crab legs come
from not actually a crab it's a
different decapodal arthropod
that's a scandal yeah and there's
there's like multiple different kinds of
king crabs
they probably evolved from hermit crabs
which also aren't actually crabs uh
and then coconut crabs which uh are
[ __ ] huge
if you want some nightmare fuel and
you're not crazy about crabs
just like google image search coconut
crabs they can be up to a meter long
um what yeah they're enormous there's
there there was like this famous picture
of a
coconut crab just like chilling out on a
trash can
and it's like the same height as the
trash can
anyway coconut crabs also not actually a
crab
um so anyway like the general crab
shape has has evolved convergently
at least five times and that is the
process of
carsonization and i think that is very
very neat
i gotta be honest that's a lot more crab
content than i bargained for and i don't
regret it at all
i mean that was that that's pretty
interesting
um the first thing i'm gonna do when we
finish recording
i gotta see some of these coconut crabs
i've shown you coconut crabs before
i must have forgotten one time during
family dinner
we were talking about like various
creatures that are like
way bigger than you'd think they would
be i remember that creepy
yeah yeah so i i think like your your
brain just got so
hung up on that indonesian bat that's
like four feet long
that you just like tuned out the rest
but yeah we talked about coconut crabs
that night too
yeah that bat was insane it was a bat
that was like the size
of an adolescent human being it's not
good it's not good
um okay well i think that does it for uh
for today's episode
like we promised that that second reddit
question we are going to answer
in the next episode um now if you want
to become
part of the conversation be sure to join
our public facebook group or pop into
our subreddit
check the uh the description of this
episode we will have a link
to both of those as always thank you for
joining us
and we'll be back in a couple weeks
thank you for listening to the stronger
by science podcast
if you enjoyed the podcast be sure to
sign up for our free newsletter to get
concise breakdowns of relevant research
as well as 28 free training programs
for all skill levels and all schedules
we hate spam just as much as you do
so we'll only email you when we have
something really interesting to share
with you
you can sign up for the free newsletter
at strongerbyscience.com
newsletter or just go to the stronger by
science homepage and click the free
programs button
at the top if you want to join in on the
stronger by science podcast conversation
be sure to check out our facebook group
and our subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits
be sure to check with a qualified health
care professional
once again thank you for listening and
we will be back soon with another
episode
of the stronger by science podcast
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you